what's going on reject nation it's Greg
Alba here so we're gonna watch the
honest trailer for the room today I
don't know how you can make an honest
trailer out of the room the perfect film
its flawless everything why became such
a hit an underground hit because of how
great of a movie it is I feel like the
real trailers are already honest enough
you know with the passion and fire of
Tennessee Williams and all that Jim
we should make movies one day we know
good film
[Music]
in a world where most movies are just
okay one film will be so bizarre so
upsetting and so aggressively bad the
sheer amount of suck will collapse in on
itself like a dying star and explode in
a supernova unintentional genius stars
in rights produces and directs a film
that puts the passion in passion project
financed by a rumored six million
dollars of his morals furious wanted and
between three long minutes of his own
mysterious butt cheeks he's a man with a
singular vision a cheap personal style
and a powerful message to share with the
world maybe it's okay to give up with
your dreams no I don't believe it I show
them journey to b-roll of San Francisco
and me Johnny you're beautiful
[Music]
sometimes his emotions really hard
sometimes he's so cold it's like he
forgets he's on camera but he always
finds color to laugh with the little
things
anything for my friend says or laugh for
no particular reason
or eleven things you really shouldn't be
laughing at one of them found out about
it beat her up so bad she ended up in a
hospital and career Oh Street dude that
is funny means a story that at its core
is a really simple love triangle where
Johnny is engaged to Lisa his wife of
the future do my future wife Lisa is
your future wife after Y but she didn't
love him I don't love him so she sleeps
with more kids best friend Johnny's my
best friend but set that aside because
the roof isn't up dangling Padres - we
look like it like this animus
unexplained game of tuxedo football
Johnny's promotion at whatever his job
finger Samara disappear throughout the
movie this drug deal that's never
mentioned again the results of the tests
back I definitely have breast cancer
ever comes back you uh you gonna react
to that no okay cool cool interesting
words but the room is not where a man
makes it a you get to see himself works
though somehow it works
in two prints at watch you see what
everyone in front of them ordered life
are you and the environments and if a
man gives us Beyonce flowers you'll see
exactly how that financial transaction
went down spoiler alert it was weird
do you like sex well not for long
because you're about to watch it amuse
approximation a little bit playing a
little boy crunched into increasing
there's two randoms act like toddlers
while they do it
oh yeah and Johnny does his best to
penetrate the area around Lisa's belly
button alarm he comes on trustus so
enjoy this real-life version of
springtime for Hitler that's the
pinnacle of so bad it's good filmmaking
spawning midnight movies greetings Oscar
caliber films about its creation yeah
and the Andorian Tommy Wiseau is where
he's from where his money comes from and
how old he is but some mysteries are
probably better left unsolved we've seen
the guys taint I don't need to know
anymore sorry football spoon art
entrances and exits I've gotta go oh hi
oh hi mark I have to go
[Music]
worries generalizing about women women
change their minds all the time you
think girls like to cheat like guys do I
never say what they mean and they always
play games sometimes are just too smart
somebody just flat-out stupid other
times they're just evil falling for no
reason not room the room very different
I like to think Lisa's mom isn't playing
a character she's a lady wandered in and
started commenting on what she saw what
are these characters doing here how many
people come in and out of this apartment
every day this is worse than Grand
Central Station you're my favorite
customer and her stupid comments in your
pocket I got the results of the tests
back I definitely have breast patches
you're tearing me apart Lisa I did not
hit her
it's not true his [ __ ] I did not hit
her
I didn't oh wow man the room the room is
a magical movie I only watched for the
first time a few weeks ago
John had grown up watching it attending
screenings throwing spoons and all that
fun stuff
I saw the disaster artist with him
that's easily one of my favorite movies
of the entire year maybe watch through
me what's a disaster ours and just
revisiting footage of the room makes you
see it very different a lot of a jokes
are there commenting on the disaster
artist really covers a lot yeah you know
like sex with the belly button laughing
out weird things like why is he laughing
right here a lot of the artists trailer
commentary is commentated on in the
disaster artist yeah all the noticeably
weird motifs of the movie at least get
touched upon along with some extras in
this video
I bet he's been to some of these
screenings because some of the things
he's calling out or like you know fan
favorite you know call back lines and
stuff like that oh yeah yeah the stuff
with the mom though is one of the more
interesting aspects to me though like
they kind of touch on it at the end here
the stinger she always shows up as if
they have a plan to hang out she enters
and exits within minutes they always
like sit and talk for a second mama busy
she leaves or she's busy and then leaves
and it's so obvious that Tommy Wiseau
wrote every line of this movie yeah
everybody shows up for short covers like
even the scene we're marking and Johnny
they go to that cafe and they're down
and talk like a couple minutes into them
sitting with before they begin their
order he's like I gotta go later mark
any food do they I don't think so
then maybe had coffee or something yeah
but there's something special about the
room when you watch the movie it is so
bad it's good in the most authentic way
possible
well yeah it's so it's super genuine and
it's clearly the work of an auteur so
yeah is that magic under some menu it's
weird how everyone is on the same I feel
like the mom is like slightly better
like the lords Graham whatever yeah at
least his mom is slightly better than
the rest of the gang guy plays Chris R
is kind of believable but kinda not
because that
story just intrudes and leaves yeah the
rest of the actors are very they're all
in the same caliber yeah they're all in
the same wavelength but the type of
acting this is and you can't get that
with intentional unintentional yet they
all hit the same wavelength the whole
entire time and this has to be a force
of nature to work the way it does every
time I see it no matter what because
I've seen a lot of so bad it's good
movies and there aren't a lot that make
you fond or maybe you want to rewatch
them at times but the room does have
this uncanny magic it's so convicted and
it's so committed to its terribleness or
just to what it is and what it is just
so happens to be kind of Terezin because
it's also the right amount of production
budget enough to get decent audio yeah
however buzzy the photography is you can
still see everything like the editing is
really weird but you know technically
speaking it's not like Birdemic where
half the time you're like what do they
say it's not like you're watching this
ultra ultra low budget movie made for
like $100,000 you're watching a six
million dollar budget movie well maybe
that's part of why is like are you guys
actually had an actual budget to like
make this kind of like an actual movie
maybe it's partly so sticky and
memorable because then I think I want to
watch the disaster artist again I
definitely want yeah just looking over
the footage just makes you look at the
room different now how accurate was the
disaster artist and portraying this
specific moment it's a prism of magic
terribleness you know every angle you
look at it from there's something else
fascinating and yeah that's partly it
feeds into the disaster artist too
because of that then you want to there I
think there are things you can catch in
both of them on multiple viewings yeah
which is part of the fun and it's
interesting watching screen junkies do a
video on a movie that so bad it's good
I'm more darkness for junkies when
they're tearing apart movie that's like
generally perceived as bad or movie
that's good and they're pointing out
flaws but to do the movie that's so bad
it's good you're like this one they
can't all the criticisms are why this
movie special day yeah we're
all the random laughing inexplicable
that was fun
Thanks screen junkies for putting this
video out man thanks guys if you guys
haven't seen the room take some time
I'll watch it and glad i watch it at
home first because I feel like going to
a theater it might miss some stuff
because people might be really loud
people say you go to one of the
screenings your first time but I really
think it works best when you get a few
people together you know have a few
drinks if you want see it the first time
so that you can just understand what it
is and then go to yeah cuz I've been
there with people who are like I don't
know what's going on I can't hear
alright well you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects subscribe to screen
junkies while you're at it you can
follow us on social media at the real
rejects and download and follow us at
the Stardust at people I reviewed the
room on that app and you did 30 solid
seconds it's all you really need that's
all you need